et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc Michael de la fosse bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous merci
socialiste de Montpellier président de
la métropole Montpellier Méditerranée on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Christel
Bertrand que vous connaissez bien c'est
le groupe La Dépêche votre presse locale
bonjour Christelle bonjour Oriane
bonjour Michael de la fosse bonjour on
va évidemment parler d'Emmanuel Macron
de congrès des mères vous étiez hier
soir à l'Élysée avec le chef de l'État
traditionnelle du président de la
République avec les maires comment ça
s'est passé vous êtes satisfait
c'est un rituel et satisfait satisfait
quand le président de la République a
commencé par des mots qui me semblait
important à l'heure où un inspecteur du
des impôts a été tué parce que il
exerçait sa mission et le président de
la République je crois au nom de tous a
condamné la violence qui envahit la
société et donc les mères sont souvent à
la fois réceptacles et nous nous
souvenons qu'un collègue il y a quelques
années et décédé alors qu'il
s'opposaient à un acte d'incivilité
insupportable
et donc il a eu cette parole là elle est
elle est importante parce que nous le
voyons en tout lieu et en tout point la
violence verbale des formes de violences
physiques
s'exprime dans notre société et il était
important hier de cueiller un propos
là-dessus et ça a été son introduction
et de ce point de vue je veux la saluer
et je veux le dire très clairement il y
a des gens ils sont professeurs ils sont
médecins ils sont policiers ils sont
inspecteurs pour ils sont fonctionnaires
ils sont dépositaires de l'autorité
publique et il ne faut pas
vous vous êtes aussi professeur vous
êtes professeur
politique n'est pas un métier mais mon
métier c'est professeur j'ai l'honneur
d'être mère non mais vous êtes inquiet
parce que on voit les violences envers
les élus elles sont augmentées de 47% il
y a dans l'étude du cvpoque il y a 63%
des élus qui disent qu'ils ont été
victimes d'incivilité est-ce que vous
vous sentez suffisamment protégé en tant
que mère est-ce que les sanctions sont
assez fortes je sais pas si c'est les
sanctions ont été renforcées le sujet
qui doit nous préoccuper ici à Public
Sénat c'est la qualité de notre débat
démocratique savons-nous nous dire que
nous ne sommes pas d'accord dans le
respect aujourd'hui les mots deviennent
l'invective et parfois le débat
parlementaire
fonctionne de ce participe à une forme
d'affaiblissement
les jeunes enfants les élèves quand ils
regardent la télévision les familles il
y a c'est des repères quand on a faiblit
quand on devient outrancier je me suis
déjà exprimé publiquement là-dessus mais
quand
un responsable politique majeur la
France insoumise dit la police tue elle
renvoie une image de Jean nous la police
elle protège comme l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires assure leur mission et
donc il faut retrouver la France
insoumise participe à cet
affaiblissement de démocratie certains
en tout cas on ne gagne jamais par
l'outrans l'irrespect nous pouvons
exprimer des idées différentes sur des
points de vue mais dans dans le respect
avoir un peu de courage dans la nuance
et je crois que le niveau de langage les
formes avec lesquels nous nous adressons
les uns les autres doivent doivent être
posés et puis il faut la clarté dès
qu'il y a un acte de violence il doit y
avoir une une sanction quand quelqu'un
est en situation de fragilité parce
qu'il exerçait une mission il doit
trouver soutien je viens de lire j'en
étais terrifié par vos confrères du
Parisien le compte-rendu de l'isolement
de Samuel Paty c'est aussi ça qui a
conduit à son assassin et aujourd'hui il
y a des gens qui sont des fonctionnaires
de la République qui peuvent sentir cela
et comme mère ça arrive aussi après être
mère voilà il faut pas avoir peur
d'affronter les problèmes d'affronter
les débats voilà et parfois aussi nous
captons les colères et les tensions de
la société et il faut surtout pas les
fuir vous parlez d'isolement Emmanuel on
a beaucoup reproché à Emmanuel Macron au
début de son quinquennat de ne pas
prendre en considération suffisante les
mères de ne pas avoir une relation
suffisamment proche et ne pas s'appuyer
sur eux est-ce que vous trouvez
aujourd'hui que sa relation au maire a
changé et
que vous êtes plus des relais
aujourd'hui auprès de lui en tout cas le
président de la République est notre
pays a besoin des maires a besoin de la
décentralisation pour faire pour agir je
l'espère je l'espère qu'il viendra moi
je l'invite à Montpellier si le souhaite
pour voir des réalisations qui engagent
la transition écologique réalisation de
ligne de tramway de bustram faire pour
construire des écoles dans des quartiers
pour aller conquérir la mixité sociale
parce qu'on vous a demandé
d'y aller de faire c'est le sujet
compliqué du Congrès des mères nous
sommes dans un moment d'incertitude avec
l'inflation avec le coût de l'énergie
qui est devenu extrêmement important et
on a été nombreux à discuter est-ce
qu'on arrête ou pas les illuminations de
Noël à Montpellier ont réduit
l'amplitude on a baissé la température
des piscines d'un degré partout on
essaye de faire des économies parce
qu'il y a une situation qui est
incertaine et nous devons bien gérer
l'argent public et aujourd'hui il est
important que le gouvernement et nous
donne de la lisibilité du point de vue
financier par exemple prendre en compte
l'inflation dans les dotations globales
de fonctionnement la suppression
parce que parce que si nous nous sommes
dans un contexte incertain qu'est-ce qui
va se passer
on va réduire nos investissements et si
on réduit nos investissements finalement
c'est le pays qui va aller moins bien
parce que nos investissements les
investissements des maires des
intercommunalités comme la métropole de
Montpellier ils sont mobilisés au
service de la transition écologique ils
sont mobilisés au service de l'éducation
de la petite enfance avec les crèches de
la qualité des espaces publics qui font
lien social et si nous réduisons nos
investissements
qui doit être votre interlocuteur
j'imagine sur le dossier on lui dit oui
on vous donne il vous donne il est là
etc mais il faut que il faut il faut que
la feuille non je dirais pas ça ce
serait trop caricatural mais il faut que
la feuille de route soit claire notre
pays la France s'est confronté les gens
parlent ainsi sur vos plateaux des
urgences d'urgence écologiques l'urgence
sociale l'urgence économique on a des
chefs d'entreprise qui sont dans des
climats un certain et bien il nous faut
donner de la lisibilité et quand vous
avez des mères qui peuvent tracer leurs
feuilles de route au niveau local bah
les entrepreneurs qui vont répondre aux
appels d'offres les administrer qui sont
en attente sur tel projet et bien mais
vous créez de la clarification sur ce
sujet parce que Christophe Bechet a
annonçait un fond vert de 2 milliards
des préverts maintenant de 1,2 milliards
est-ce que cet après-midi vous attendez
d'Elizabeth Bank qu'elle vous en dise
plus est-ce que c'est clair pour vous ce
fond vert je crois que en tout cas il
faut vraiment créer ces conditions qui
ne sont il faut réduire ce climat de
défiance entre État et collectivités
territoriale et la question des
stratégies pour financer les projets au
plus proche des habitants pour répondre
aux problèmes qui sont rencontrés c'est
essentiel et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
avec l'explosion du prix de l'énergie
avec l'inflation avec
y compris parfois les injonctions que
nous donnent l'État en disant il
faudrait travailler ce sujet travailler
sur ce sujet il faut qu'on ait moins de
faire je prends un exemple là on
investissement en fonctionnement
question de sécurité question de
sécurité elles sont essentielles pour
nos concitoyens moi comme mère de
Montpellier j'ai signé un contrat de
sécurité intégré l'État a mis des
policiers supplémentaires et c'est une
bonne chose et je me suis engagé à créer
une police métropolitaine des transports
pour garantir la sécurité dans les
transports en commun pour que aucune
femme ne se sent en danger que les
personnes âgées ne disent pas à Monsieur
le Maire bon c'est bien les tram mais
non il faut pouvoir ce sont des dépenses
de fonctionnement il faut pouvoir les
sécuriser et on dit que on doit
travailler ensemble sur les questions de
sécurité il faut une lisibilité des des
moyens et pas être de sécurité date de
Jean castexte de sécurité vous signez
mais vous engagez et vous engagez
financièrement sur plusieurs années donc
en un seul coup vous prenez l'inflation
et le coût de l'énergie et bien voilà
et qu'on soit très attentif enfin là je
le dis d'un point de vue des finances il
faut donner
de manière très claire une lisibilité un
message de confiance alors de confiance
pas le pack de confiance qui vise à
encadrer les dépenses des collectivités
locales moi mes dépenses de
fonctionnement elles augmentent parce
que montpellier est une ville qui gagne
des habitants parce qu'à Montpellier il
y a des projets et donc dire qu'on vous
encadre avec 0,5 points en dessous
l'inflation non ça c'est pas sérieux
voilà le retour de Cahors alors je sais
que pour certains noter le spectateurs
c'est c'est peu lisible mais la
limitation des hausses des dépenses de
fonctionnement des plus grandes
collectivités le pack de cas on est tenu
de d'avoir des comptes en équilibre on a
toujours intérêt à bien gérer parce que
demain c'est pour investir puis c'est
notre propre crédité c'est une ligne
rouge cet encadrement des dépenses c'est
une ligne rouge ah moi j'appelle à ne
pas s'embarquer dans ce dispositif je
crois qu'il y aurait beaucoup de sagesse
de ce point de vue au gouvernement qu'il
a fait passer alors que le Sénat avait
voté contre que l'Assemblée avait voté
contre dans le 49-3 un petit peu en
catimini d'ailleurs
pour pour les parlementaires et pour les
élus ou venir pas jusque là le 49-3
jamais agréable pour le Parlement et
ah oui non là ça c'est c'est pas
l'esprit de la décentralisation
d'ailleurs heureusement que la
contrainte de Cahors a été ajournée au
moment de la crise covid et donc là les
collectivités ont pu faire face à
l'urgence sanitaire et donc les masques
organisés les protections et là on doit
affronter une urgence qui est le prix de
l'énergie qui est de en ce moment à
Montpellier on on a des associations qui
sont mobilisées que nous subventionnons
pour aller former les gens les plus
fragiles aux éco-gestes donc vous
demandez est-ce que ce soit la journée à
nouveau non sois pas engagé
ça s'appelle une fausse bonne idée par
contre les collectivités elle doit être
elles doivent être bien gérées et ça moi
je suis tout à fait prêt à en discuter
et c'est normal c'est normal mais donc
oui il y a un pack sur les dépenses mais
pas de coercition pas de contrat du
sérieux du sérieux dans les dépenses de
la capacité à faire dans l'intérêt du
pays un dernier mot qu'est-ce que vous
attendez Elisabeth borne cet après-midi
puisqu'il viendra s'exprimer devant les
maires de France
de clarification enfin aujourd'hui la
France est confrontée à l'immense défis
nous prenons des engagements
internationaux sur la question du climat
et bien il faut qu'on soit en capacité
d'accélérer au risque de désespérer la
jeunesse nous sommes attendus sur la
question du logement enfin nous avons
nos amis allemands Renov 5 fois plus de
logements que nous cette question là
elle est sur le plan thermique elle est
essentielle pour protéger les plus
fragiles face à la question de l'énergie
aujourd'hui il y a du chômage moi je ne
crois pas cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui stigmatise les chômeurs mais
par contre si nous investissons nous
pour et si nous avons des crédits
notamment les départements pour faire de
l'insertion nous pouvons remobiliser les
gens vers l'emploi et les sortir des
situations de détresse dans lesquelles
ils sont un dernier mot sur la question
des énergies cristal oui arrive au
Parlement le texte sur les énergies
renouvelables qui vous concerne
directement vous les maires notamment
parce
[Musique]
qui dit dans 20 ans ou 15 ans ou
peut-être 10 plus de plus de charbon
donc Emmanuel Macron a raison de
redévelopper le nucléaire pour notre
souveraineté moi je le dis très
clairement il faut le nucléaire est une
énergie que nous avons elle doit être
soutenue aujourd'hui un de nos problèmes
c'est que la moitié de nos réacteurs
sont à l'arrêt et maintenant il faut
développer tambour battant le
photovoltaïque les choses qui bois
l'installation d'éolienne dans le
respect des paysages moi je défends
l'éolienne en mer à 10 km de notre
littoral mais si nous ne faisons pas
rapidement si nous s'il y a un décalage
entre nous voulons et le la réalité et
bien nous serons en difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que l'énergie
est chère on va parler d'un sujet qui
concerne particulièrement votre région
c'est la corrida puisque cet après-midi
est examinée à l'Assemblée nationale
l'interdiction de la corridate exportée
par l'insoumi MRI Caron qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de ce texte est-ce que vous
vous appelez les députés socialistes à
ne pas le voter
je suis pas favorable à la cor j'y vais
pas c'est pas mais je sais qu'il y a des
gens qui sont attachés c'est une
tradition
vous le voteriez si vous étiez
parlementaire et je pense que au
Parlement il y a d'autres sujets que
nous devons traiter et un sujet par
exemple qu'on doit traiter c'est la
crise des médecins et on devrait se
mobiliser pour multiplier par 4 le
médecin le nombre de médecins que nous
allons former parce qu'aujourd'hui dans
10 ans on aura des difficultés voilà et
je pense que nous devrions nous attacher
à qu'il y ait des débats sur ce sujet
c'est très respectable mais l'énergie du
Parlement elle doit être clairement mise
sur les problèmes des gens la question
de la santé est une priorité les
questions éducatives sont aujourd'hui
enfin les classements pizzas sont pas
bon les questions il paraît qu'il y
avait un projet de loi pour essayer de
protéger socialement les salariés de
uber et ben ça ce sont quand même des
sujets d'urgence
clairement la protection de ces jeunes
gens qui travaillent quasiment 12 heures
par jour 7 jours sur 7 en tout cas pour
la gauche c'est un sujet qui doit être
prioritaire et pour la gauche les
questions souffrances animales ont sans
prioritaire aussi vous appartenez un
parti qui les a souvent mis en avant
est-ce que vous comprenez que ça puisse
mais choquer je veux même vous le dire à
Montpellier par exemple nous faisons des
il y a des cirques sans animaux parce
que nous savions qu'il y avait de la
maltraitance par exemple nous avons
proposé à la cantine l'option
végétarien
dont se débat est mené ça crée des
tensions ça crée du clivage il y a des
gens qui se sentent
agressés parce que ils auraient eu il
serait allé un spectacle de corrida
enfin je crois pas qu'on construit je ne
crois pas que notre République se
construit sur l'invective sur la déf en
permanence j'ai comme le sentiment que
cette tradition est de moins en moins
influente et peut-être que qui est des
débats c'est légitime mais là aller sur
l'interdiction moi je vois vous voyez il
y a une femme qui remarquable qui est
éditrice Au diable vauvert Marion mazori
qui voilà qui est très attaché à cette
tradition qui ressens ça ben comme comme
une agression donc on a aussi besoin de
mener de manière un peu sereine des
débats dans la société monsieur
Caron a ses convictions d'ontact pour
moi la priorité du Parlement c'est quand
même les questions sociales c'est quand
même les questions républicaines c'est
de répondre aux enjeux de de menaces
d'atteinte à la laïcité enfin c'est
là-dessus localement certains de vos
élus ont demandé à ce qu'un débat puisse
se tenir à Montpellier sur cette
question de la corrida est-ce que vous
allez l'organiser non mais moi si on
veut une salle pour pouvoir débattre de
sujets je l'apprête je suis attaché
parce que le débat démocratique
mais au conseil de métropole nous
soutenons par exemple les traditions
comme la course camarguaise voilà donc
il y a pas de problème de ce point de
vue mais un conseil de métropole il a un
ordre du jour la question de l'inflation
la question de la candidature à la
capitale européenne de la culture voilà
c'est ça nos ce sont ça quand parce que
la métropole n'a pas de compétences sur
ce sujet
voilà
on va parler du Parti socialiste sur
Adrien cadenas puisque son ancien épouse
a formé de nouvelles accusations contre
lui de violences psychologiques
physiques qui ont été exercée depuis des
années alors lui dément le groupe la
France insoumise dit qu'il ne
participera plus au groupe jusqu'à la
décision de justice c'est la bonne
réponse où il aurait fallu aller plus
loin et appeler à sa démission c'est le
problème de Monsieur catenens c'est
qu'il a fait des tweets
sur ces questions des violences faites
aux femmes et donc il est renvoyé à sa
propre cohérence les déclarations de son
ex-épouse
sont sont extrêmement troublantes et la
question des violences faites aux femmes
ne doit pas être traité à la légère et
je crois que c'est sa conscience qui est
interrogée et lui qui a dit tant de
choses sur les bancs du Parlement
devraient tirer les conséquences
politiques de cela probablement en
démissionnant je crois après que la
justice doit pouvoir travailler c'est
pas à nous de nous ériger en procureur
c'est mais il faut être très ferme
là-dessus mais je veux aussi nous le
dire sereinement il faut que la justice
elle travaille il faut qu'on fasse
attention à des sujets de tribunal
médiatique monsieur Bayou je ne connais
pas particulièrement d'un seul coup
c'est retrouver quand même mis en cause
alors je vais peut-être pas apparaître
dans l'air du temps c'est à dire dans
Twitter qui se déchaîne mais enfin moi
je crois quand même aux droits de la
défense Robert Badinter est une
référence et si les médias permettent le
débat démocratique ils ne peuvent pas
s'ériger en tribunal la vraie question
pour Monsieur Catana c'est la cohérence
entre ces déclarations politiques ou à
juste titre il a condamné les violences
faites aux femmes et sa propre attitude
personnelle où on ressent un immense
décalage et la question des violences
faites aux femmes comment d'une
exemplarité d'un point de vue politique
et commande surtout une un engagement de
la chaîne judiciaire de manière efficace
pour protéger les femmes et aujourd'hui
le groupe France insoumise j'ai lu son
communiqué il faut qu'on se dise les
choses
eux qui souvent font la leçon à tout le
monde
il devrait bien faire un monde honorable
parce qu'il paraît que le retour était
prévu et tout ça a été théâtralisé bon
bref
c'est soyons du côté soyons du côté des
femmes et Monsieur catenas sa conscience
devrait facile et cohérent avec les
convictions qui sont les siennes ils
devraient être démissionner venons-en à
votre parti politique le parti
socialiste qui organise en congrès au
mois de janvier et donc qui va avoir ou
pas un nouveau premier secrétaire
Olivier Faure sont plutôt en bonne voie
pour l'emporter bonne chose selon vous
ou pas vous connaissez le résultat des
élections avant l'heure ça c'est pas bon
signe
très clairement
que nous cherchons
des élections législatives c'est pas un
succès de votre point de vue je ne vois
pas beaucoup de succès aujourd'hui on a
du mal à voir ce que pensent les
socialistes sur beaucoup de sujets
et le rôle d'un parti politique c'est de
continuer simplement à l'Assemblée
au débat d'idées c'est de porter ses
idées sur les territoires et donc
aujourd'hui vous êtes capable de me dire
quelle est la position des socialistes
sur les sujets qui sont la question qui
préoccupe les gens la retraite bon moi
je ne suis pas favorable à augmenter
l'âge légal pour le maintien de la
retraite à 62 ans avec une prise en
compte de la pénibilité voilà et nous
devons dire ça le Parti socialiste n'est
pas un parti pour l'instant au travail
je le dis et il faut qu'il travaille sur
les idées il y a beaucoup de gens de
gauche qui aujourd'hui apparaissent
déboussolés nous sentons bien d'ailleurs
il doit aussi se clarifier à ce qu'il
compose avec le populisme ou est-ce
qu'il combat le populisme qui existe
aujourd'hui dans notre démocratie et à
gauche c'est un débat qu'est-ce que le
Parti socialiste c'est la France
insoumise
il existe des formes de populisme qui
existent au sein de cette formation
d'ailleurs ils l'ont théorisé Chantal
mouf le populisme de gauche non moi je
ne crois que la gauche républicaine elle
doit avoir le courage de la nuance elle
doit tenir des positions
qui doivent être argumentés crédibles et
elle doit travailler pour proposer un
projet de transformation à la société
aujourd'hui
c'est on a aussi les préoccupations
électorales et sans être à ce dossier à
la France insoumise on aura plus de mal
notamment en cas de dissolution à avoir
des élus au Parlement vous savez Parti
socialiste il reste 20 000 adhérents
tout le monde est parti parce que
justement il y avait plus le sentiment
que cette formation politique ce grand
courant qui est le qui est le courant de
Gauche socialiste et bien il est pas au
travail sur les idées et sur les projets
moi voyez à Montpellier on fait des
choses la gratuité des transports nous
posons la question de la laïcité comme
un enjeu essentiel comme
le maire de Montpellier et j'ai fait une
promesse c'est d'assumer pleinement mes
fonctions et mon engagement il est là
oui c'est incompatible parce qu'il faut
du temps parce qu'il faut répondre à vos
invitations pour aller défendre les
idées toujours avec plaisir là je viens
pour le congrès des mères et et voilà et
donc il y a il y aura le reste des
personnes qui vont se
proposer et il faudra les soutenir moi
je soutiens est un des talents Nicolas
meilleur rossignol est un des talents il
y a plein de gens qui Valérie rabot
président du du groupe ici
Patrick est en d'autres et moi je
soutiens la démarche dite de de
refondation mais je le dis le Parti
socialiste il doit travailler sur le
fond est tranché des positions être dans
la clarté ne jamais être conclusion de
la gauche
est-ce que non mais est-ce que ça doit
se reconstruire au sein du PS ou en
dehors est-ce que vous appelez à bâtir
un mouvement en dehors du Parti
socialiste non aujourd'hui c'est Michel
Rocard il a fallu s'entendre pour faire
une marque voilà le mot socialiste c'est
un mot qui a une force qui est pour
beaucoup de gens mais aujourd'hui que
disent les socialistes sur la grande
question de l'écologie sur les questions
du travail est-ce que les socialistes
vont continuer à ne pas parler de
sécurité si vous êtes pas d'accord avec
François Hollande par exemple qui lui
imagine un mouvement en dehors du Parti
socialiste
je ne le savais pas
je pense que aujourd'hui il y a de
nombreux élus locaux socialistes et
d'ailleurs vous m'avez présenté ainsi
qui contribue à changer la vie des gens
à faire à mener des politiques de
justice sociale qui agissent c'est comme
ça la grande force des socialistes enfin
quand la région Occitanie la région
Aquitaine la région Centre la région
Bretagne c'est des élus qui font
beaucoup sur les questions d'éducation
sur les questions de justice imaginez
que demain on confie ça à la droite
et on a compris c'est très clair vous
devez filer au Congrès des mamicales de
la fausse merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
été notre invité